busy night tonight welcome to hannity we
will begin tonight with multiple news
breaking
news stories tonight an urgent situation
in multiple cities chaos
deadly violence in seattle's so-called
autonomous
chopped chaz oh summer free love zone
we'll take you there in a moment and
chaos
in washington dc tonight demonstrators
attempting to create
their own autonomous zone right there in
our nation's capital outside of the
white house
now before we get to our opening
monologue let's go live to washington
d.c
where fox news is kevin cork is standing
by with a live report
apparently we lost oh kevin is there
kevin tell us what you got
okay we don't have kevin we had him we
don't have all right tonight we do have
other
breaking news we'll get back to that in
a moment that was earlier tonight now
we'll also take you on the ground of
seattle
for a live report we'll bring breaking
news there as it's happening everywhere
also the secretary of state mike pompeo
will join us tonight
on top of all this breaking news
violence has been now erupting in
america's major cities all weekend long
it is bad
shootings robberies assault this weekend
we saw carnage
on an absolutely shocking and
unacceptable level if we want to be a
country a united
states the first thing we need to
establish is safety
and security bottom line next thing we
might want to do is fix these broken
schools
you are watching a rapid deterioration
and disintegration of our major cities
democratic mayors and governors who have
been in charge for decades are now
clueless
unable unwilling to fix it these are
our fellow american citizens they have
failed their constituents
year in year out now americans are
suffering
we are watching this far left radical
agenda
play out in real time and frankly it is
a sad it is a scary picture
and we're going to take a closer look at
america's liberal cities in crisis
because in 134 days you will be the
ultimate jury
and what is now becoming visible for all
to see in all these liberal cities
and these liberal states well if they
win in november in 134 days and they
implement their new green deal
and their radical leftist agenda you can
pretty much assume the same results
we start with the news in seattle as
we've been reporting now democrats there
have ruled that city for three decades
eight straight democrats have served as
mayor
it's a one-party town crime is spiraling
out of control
in fact violent crime is up by 30
percent the past three years
in february the downtown seattle
business association openly worried
that the city quote could be ruined by
drugs random attacks
shootings and homelessness but that
didn't stop the democratic mayor of
seattle jenny durkin from
well ceding what six city blocks
the main part of seattle to literally
a collection of anarchists radicals
socialists and other so-called
protesters
she let them take over parts of an
entire city
including a police precinct we saw them
burn down in new york and other cities
and literally all law enforcement were
kicked out now she allowed them to
wall off an entire area basically
commandeer it take it over
and prevent stores from conducting their
business and protecting
american business owners and workers she
let them literally light fires breaking
into the buildings and spray paint
nearly every surface with graffiti she
said oh well how long is this going to
go on
oh she said it might be a whole summer
of love with a lot of
potluck spaghetti dinners right mayor
this is what you said right
how long do you think seattle in those
few blocks looks like this
i don't know we could have the summer of
love
well tell that to the police who was
supposed to be in that precinct
multiple media outlets also referring to
this lawless area
oh as a festive zone even as the
anarchists themselves
well telling the media fake news cnn
msdnc
while they're live on the air this is
not a festive zone they still report it
as a festive zone
didn't look too festival because festive
over the weekend
multiple people shot in the so-called
festive zone
we told you on this show this is not
going to end well
we have been warning all we must protect
every american we have got to have law
in order
we've got to stop the assault on police
now we're headed now towards 900
injured police officers with rocks and
bricks and bottles and molotov cocktails
and some have died
and on top of some dying we have the guy
in vegas a cop shot
and is now paralyzed from the neck down
for the rest of his life
and then other the looting the arson
it's got to stop
the media also needs to stop lying and
say it's a festive zone when it's not a
festive zone
now there were peaceful protesters they
deserve everyone was
unanimous on the george floyd case there
was very little disagreement that can't
happen in this country
in one instance we had police
desperately trying to get to the scene
of the shooting in the festive zone
autonomous owned but they were blocked
in seattle by angry individuals watch
this
please move out of the way so we can get
to the victims
all we're trying to do is
mayor durkin what happened to your
summer of love where are you
where's governor inslee this is your
state the president
has been begging both of you to accept
his help
just like comrade de blasio governor
cuomo
offered help again and again just like
chicago just like illinois
president offering help to everybody oh
we don't want any help we can handle
this well it didn't work out too well
and that was highly predictable mayor
durkin finally tonight
just breaking all of a sudden wants to
wind down the summer of love in the chop
zone and the chas
zone really no more summer of love mayor
all told one person killed two others
gravely injured
during this weekend's violence in the
so-called well
capitol hill occupied protest or chop as
one business owner put it quote
chop destroyed the neighborhood it made
us everyone there feel
unsafe and as you can see mayor durkin
well your wind down is a little
too little too late now we're going to
see the same thing in nearly every
major liberal city we must for the
safety and security of all americans
restore law and restore order now these
democratic governors and mayors have
refused to do so
let's go to chicago as an example that's
been ruled by
democrats now and mayors democratic
mayors since 1933.
want to know why it's a mess there you
go city's government soft on crime
approach
has led to a seemingly never-ending wave
of violence over the weekend this past
weekend
104 our fellow americans were shot
including
12 children 14 people died
this weekend it's kind of like well just
a little bit above
average in chicago they do nothing to
save that city and the people keep them
safe and secure even in their own homes
never mind the dilapidated broken down
corrupt school system
where kids don't learn reading writing
and math in new york city comrade de
blasio
oh two terms in office well guess what
he wrecked the once
peaceful city that he inherited his
anti-police soft on crime policies along
with cuomo's
get out of jail free no bail reform is
destroying
not only new york city but new york
state and they stand by their stupidity
just like they were awful on coronavirus
look at new york city shootings up a
whopping 358 percent over last year
just this weekend new york city 28
separate shootings 38 victims
now think do you know the names of any
of our fellow americans
in chicago seattle new york do you know
the names of those individuals shot
those kids that were shot those people
that died
no the media barely reports it
minneapolis where democrat has been
mayor since 1978
also violence spiraling out of control
again at least there the president did
get an opportunity to go in and help
stop the violence in minneapolis
before the pandemic serious crimes were
up by 70 percent of course now
after the city council has now vowed to
dismantle the entire police department
guess what seven police officers
announced their resignation
violent crime has ensued in just one
shooting over the weekend
11 people were injured there one dead
there again our fellow americans
this isn't just a failure of leadership
on the state local level
nationally top democrats they have
turned a blind eye to violent crime for
decades joe biden
okay joe you're going to lecture
everybody and terry mcauliffe
i'm fine with joe in the basement he
only sees two people a day
he's two people that's all he sees you
know and there his body man i'm fine
leave him there
he's been in politics 51 years joe what
did you do after ferguson
what did you do after baltimore what did
you do after cambridge nothing
speaker pelosi wow she's been in
politics 44 years
senior senator from california dianne
feinstein has been
well a public office now for over three
decades maxine waters has held office in
1976 patrick leahy
he's been in the u.s senate a whopping
45 years
what have they done these democrats all
claim to care about
america's inner cities what have they
done decade after decade after decade
every two years every four years what do
we hear conservatives are racists
they are sexist misogynists homophobic
xenophobic islamophobic they want dirty
air and water and they want
to kill children and want to throw
grandma and grandpa over a cliff
it's the same playbook by the democrats
every two and four years it's not true
because under donald trump's leadership
record after record low unemployment
african americans hispanic americans
asian americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment
and african american youth unemployment
didn't happen under barack and joe
when they had eight years they had 13
million more americans on food stamps 8
million more in poverty
and the lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s they've been more focused
on expanding
power and the scope of government over
freedom in the lives of law abiding
americans who are not being protected in
our cities
women and children and moms and dads and
grandmas and grandpas
while they've been coddling criminals in
these big cities
letting criminals out sanctuary cities
sanctuary states
and wreaking havoc on america's streets
rule 101 if you want to live free
you need law and you need order and you
need safety and you need security for
the american people
that's a simple hannity rule i think all
americans can agree on
and the next thing let's fix america's
broken dilapidated
frankly what is a despicable amount of
money we spend more per capita than any
other industrialized nation on education
with the worst results
how is that possible how's it possible
in the city of baltimore
third highest per capita spending on
students
in the entire world and guess what there
are 13 public high schools not one kid
is proficient in math not one the veil
has now been lifted
socialism is on the ballot safety and
security is on the ballot
and certainly of dilapidated school
system
is on the ballot and donald trump's
record of success versus biden's record
of failure in 50 years in politics
that's on the ballot in 134 days
which america do you choose because this
is now the biggest choice election
in the history of the country but i
don't want to go too hypebolic on this
make no mistake socialism it's
radicalism
it is the one philosophy that has been
tried one incarnation after another
worldwide it has failed again and again
and again every time they try it no
matter how they try to sell it
it all ends up in failure power for the
state and the people end up in poverty
otherwise venezuela would be the richest
country on earth that is what is at
stake for this country in 134 days in
other words
if they actually implement their new
green deal get rid of oil and gas and
make everything free free free
it's going to fail it is mathematically
impossible
to to actually do what they say they're
going to do
will we triumph or will we fail we will
fail and america
will become unrecognizable well in about
40 some odd days
i have it all laid out in my book live
free or die
america and the world on the brink and
that is now
well out august 4th but that is on the
ballot in 134 days
america is and has been great for a
reason not perfect great
it's built on principles freedom rugged
individualism self-sufficiency
democrats they now want to fundamentally
rip out those core principles
and it's up to you the people i'm only
one little vote in new york
i can't vote more than once i do it
legally i do it the right way
but you know what sanctuary cities
sanctuary states
border policies if you believe
everything's going to be free well just
look at chicago
look at illinois look at new york city
look at new york state
look at new jersey look at california
and tell me you want that to be america
because that's what america will become
otherwise this country will never be the
same again as my prediction
they win guess what this country will be
unrecognizable
if these plans are ever implemented what
we are seeing what we're witnessing in
these cities we will see nationwide here
with